it's not something you can just kind of
forget about really the harry potter
team went through a ton of tissues when
they were filming the intense moments
from the series like the passing of
characters torture scenes and a very
special moment on just the second day of
filming let's dive into these 15 scenes
that were the most emotional for the
actors to film and often for us to watch
number one say it ain't so serious
we were devastated just watching sirius
black's untimely death so it's no
surprise dan radcliffe faced his own
struggle when it came time to actually
film i always loved the character
serious i loved the relationship harry
and sirius have he's like this cool
uncle but also older brother a
combination of emotions made it
difficult but the fact that the actor
had recently lost a family member made
the whole moment that much more painful
to go through the character's death just
come so out of the blue as well and it
was obvious in radcliff's chilling
scream that was just so haunting they
couldn't even include it in the movie
number two
being tortured on set is no fun at all
so no one can blame emma watson for
having a tough time filming the scene
but she wasn't the only one moved by her
performance
it was very intense to film i was
actually surprised by how affecting i
found it crew members were left
extremely disturbed witnessing the
painful and intense acting watson got so
caught up in it she had no idea how long
she'd even been performing for and david
yates had to cut the actress off even
though emma wanted to keep going by the
end of it i was i was a bit of a stage i
couldn't stop crying it's like quite
hard when you get yourself into
something like that two minutes of
screaming pretending to endure torture
isn't fun for anyone
number three
it may not be a scene per se but their
most recent time on set brought about a
whole lot of emotions are we surprised
it's been lovely to see everyone it
really has been back to reflect on all
the memories and visit those spaces that
held so much we're not sure they could
have planned for enough tissues on set
we're thinking the filming process was a
total tear fest it's just been a joy
getting to relive it all we get the
chance to hang out with each other which
has been a real privilege number four
wait
right now
thinking kind of next year we'll be back
but we really we really weren't and it
really is the end poor watson and grint
were struck numb when they heard the
team call a wrap on their final scene
i feel like i've blocked out the memory
because it's almost it was almost like
too much after so many years taking a
moment to acknowledge the fact that they
wouldn't be playing their characters
anymore led to a whole lot of emotions
we were the chosen ones yeah
uh yeah we were for the always strong
and sharp hermione the tears were
unexpected but very warranted and she
definitely wasn't alone and feeling that
way
yeah
i miss can't play wrong
number five
once bellatrix was done it was a wrap on
the character and the actress
bellatrix's sudden end filled the
actress with grief even though it was a
pretty killer moment for mrs weasley not
only did her character pass away but it
marked the end of her time actually
filming talk about finality i've got
very attached to bellatrix she's been a
friend to me
number six
reliving one of the most heartbreaking
tragedies over and over again for a
camera is not easy work oliver phelps
was totally overwhelmed having to go
through watching his twin pass away take
after take that after just three the
team actually had to move on the whole
oliver and james actually being twins
factor definitely made the experience
more intense
we were in tears and we aren't even
related to them
number seven
on the other end was james who while he
didn't have to witness his brother
hurting he did have to go to a pretty
dark place himself a surreal moment is
what he called it the fact was while
phelps himself was fine the character
he'd played and loved for years was gone
i feel like a really close friend has
died it was obviously a pretty
exhausting day since the actor actually
fell asleep in the end anyway not even
waking up when everyone finished and
cleared the set
number eight
how do you just stop playing the role
you've carried for a decade i love this
place this has been my life harry was in
the last shot of the day and as soon as
they called rap the actor almost
instantly began crying there'll never be
a frame of any of these films that i
don't look at and connect immediately to
a memory those tears kept flowing
through to the
know what my wrap
life consists of without you all of you
and after that speech we doubt there was
a dry eye in the house
number nine
the room of requirement has seen plenty
of tears there were quite a few shed by
ivana lynch after her final scene in
there i cried on the last day because it
was epic it was a bit of a full circle
moment for the actress to film that
scene i felt like i'd started on the
room of requirement scene and that was
like a learning curve and you learn
magic and then we left and we go out
into battle and i felt it was so
symbolic
okay yep we're crying again
number 10
okay so there weren't full-fledged tears
but this malfoy got awfully close
filming the glimpse of the future we see
caught tom felton right in the fields
especially since he got to perform it
standing next to his girlfriend at the
time jade olivia kind of like
bittersweet goodbye even though it
wasn't his final scene the actor knew it
would close off the series so no doubt
that meant a whole lot of pressure came
with it too that wasn't the toughest
though
seeing harry all grown up was actually
what did it for felton there was
something really nice about seeing
daniel with his kids at the end i really
thought daniel did a marvelous job being
older i got a bit emotional about that
number 11
before during and after the whole day
was an intense ride for gary oldman the
order of the phoenix set saw some pretty
heartbreaking moments including of
course sirius's heartbreaking end pacing
around beforehand getting into character
and mentally ready for the scene was
tough because in rehearsals oldman had
never really felt the moment turned out
quite right wanting to do justice for
the iconic scene made for a completely
overwhelming and emotional time he
wasn't going to fake it and luckily he
didn't have to this scene always gets us
number 12.
married with kids and back where it all
began a beautiful and heart-wrenching
time it was very sad and it was kind of
quite strangely emotional bonnie wright
was totally overwhelmed when she had to
film the epilogue of the movie as so
many others were
number 13
one very special actor had just one day
on set appearing in a scene that didn't
even make the cut but it was an
extremely emotional time the young actor
was actually a guest on set
little jay had come to visit and really
wanted to be in the movie as soon as
alan rickman heard the wish he went full
snape mode commanding that jay be part
of the film only his back actually makes
a short appearance in the final cut but
the memory and gift given by rickman
meant the world
number 14
he may not have been in the scene but
director chris columbus played a huge
role in these actors lives so in a way
he kind of was part of the scene
watching the young trio film their first
farewell a gem of a moment moved
columbus to tears on what was just their
second day of filming
we knew we were on to something with dan
and that's day two of shooting
those are the kinds of surprises you got
from kids who had not been on a film set
before
it clearly didn't take long for the
director to know they had something
special on their hands it's also an
adorable scene gets us right in the
feels every time
number 15.
this was one ending that brought on
double the tears
literally the epilogue scene an
emotional one for everyone was actually
shot twice because the whole crew became
too overwhelmed filming the first time
around i think we just pushed ourselves
too far too quickly to get that all done
at king's cross there were a few factors
at play here they were all super
emotional to begin with and how the
pressure of trying to capture what was
needed in a very limited amount of time
i think we made it very hard on
ourselves we get emotional just watching
them we can't even imagine how hard
these moments must have been to witness
and experience up close we need more
tissues asap anyone else